This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
From BBC Learning English
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English.
I'm Cuthren.
And I'm Rob.
And today we'll bring you a techie topic
along with 6 up-to-date vocabulary items.
That's right.
And today's techie topic is smartphones.
So Rob, can you tell me which age group
have been buying smartphones at the fastest rate
over the last five years here in the UK?
Is it A 15 to 35-year-olds?
B 35 to 55-year-olds?
Or C 55 to 75-year-olds?
OK. It's got to be the youngsters, hasn't it?
It's got to be the 15 to 35-year-olds.
Oh, well, we'll see whether you got that right or wrong
later on in the show.
Now, Rob, a question.
How old is your smartphone?
OK, well mine, I bought a couple of years ago.
And are you happy with it?
Yes, I am. It works just fine.
It does everything I need it to do.
So you're not worried about not having the latest model?
Not at all. My phone works really well.
It has all the functionality I need.
And I'm not convinced that the latest model offers
any more than the one I've got, to be honest.
Right. Well, functionality refers to the range of functions
a computer or other electronic device can perform.
So let's listen now to Andrew Olowsky
from the tech news website, The Register.
He explains why people are holding onto their phones
longer instead of rushing out to buy the latest model of phone.
What's happened is that prices have gone up at the high end.
And it's a kind of a cycle where people hang on to their phones for longer.
Therefore, manufacturers charge more.
And then people hang on to them longer to justify that higher purchase.
So big brand names like iPhone and Samsung make phones
at the high end of the market, meaning the expensive ones.
So once people have bought a handset, they hang onto it.
If you hang onto something, you keep it.
I've been hanging onto my phone for a couple of years and I'm hoping I won't need to change it
for another year or so, at least.
But what happens is if people aren't replacing their phones,
the phone manufacturers don't make a big enough profit.
So they start charging more.
And this in turn makes people hang onto their phones even longer.
So that's why Andrew Olowsky calls it a cycle.
That's where one event leads to another and then off to repeats itself.
So where will the cycle end?
Good question.
Let's listen to Andrew again talking about where he thinks the smartphone market is heading.
I think it's a very mature market now and you have to compare say a £900
galaxy note or a £1000 iPhone with a spectacular TV, you can £49
inch TV, you can get for £450.
Now longer has that kind of must-have luster that it might have had four or five years ago.
So what does mature mean, Rob?
Mature means fully grown.
We're mature adults, for example, gathering.
And in a business context, a mature market is where supply is equal to demand.
And if something has must-have luster, what's that?
A must-have item is something you feel you must have.
And luster means shine.
Ooh, I love shining new things, especially when it's a nice piece of new tech.
But £1000 is a lot of money for a phone.
A spectacular £49 inch TV for only £450 sells like a bargain though.
My TV's only got a small screen.
Yeah, we'll stop there, Catherine.
It's time for the answer to today's question.
Okay, so which age group have been buying smartphones at the fastest rate over the last five years
here in the UK? Is it a 15 to 35-year-olds,
b 35 to 55-year-olds, or c 55 to 75-year-olds?
And I said the youngsters 15 to 35-year-olds.
And you are absolutely wrong, I'm afraid, Rob.
The answer is 55 to 75-year-olds.
Although research also highlighted that this age group tended to use their smartphones
less than younger people, the study was based on a sample of 1163 people questioned
between May and June in 2017.
Hmm, interesting.
Okay, well I think it's time we looked back at the words we learned today.
Our first word is functionality, which refers to the range of functions a computer
or other electronic device can perform.
These two computers are similar in terms of both their price and functionality.
Good example, Catherine.
Number two, if you hang on to something, you keep it.
For example, you should hang on to your old TV, Catherine.
There's nothing wrong with a 30-inch screen.
Thanks for the advice, Rob.
And our next word is cycle.
That's where one event leads to another and then often repeats itself.
For example, I'm in a bad cycle of going to bed late and then over sleeping in the morning.
You need to sort yourself out, Catherine.
You're spending too much time on social media and all that blue screen time makes it very hard
to fall asleep. The last thing you need is a bigger TV.
You're probably right.
Okay, so the adjective mature means fully grown or fully developed.
And here's an example of the verb form.
My investments have matured and they're worth a lot of money now.
Right, moving on.
A must-have item is something you feel you must have.
For example, check out the latest must-have tech bargains on our website.
Like a huge TV.
Yes.
And finally, luster, which means shine.
For example, I polished my brass door knob until it's shone with a pleasing luster.
Okay, so before Rob heads off to polish his door knob,
and I nip out to buy a big new television,
please remember to check out our Facebook, Twitter and YouTube pages.
Bye-bye.
Bye.